I'm gonna say volume you I'm even going
to write just for my sake okay all you
know is a function of my height because
I think there's a function of different
things if I wanted to I can say that
that's going to be equal to length times
width times height that's it that's my
function okay
now remembering that what I want is a
maximum turning point how do I find the
maximum turning point of a graph fine I
need to differentiate first right
because that will tell me where this
thing it stops and it turns and all that
kind of thing okay so out of this I'm
gonna need DV on D H DB on D H this is
what I'm differentiating and this this H
is what I'm differentiating with respect
to okay that's the variable I'm
interested now I could differentiate it
like that but that's kinda gross looking
right I want to write it in such a form
that out makes it easy for me to do that
okay so I'm going to do some expansion
but I'm not gonna do all of them okay so
for instance I want to take as many
constants out of them out of place but I
can write what constants can i factor
out of this I can factor 2 out this and
I can factor 2 out of this do you see
that so I can take out four okay I'm
gonna do that I've got my H hanging out
there right I would deal with him in a
second
but what what that leaves me with once
I've taken out the factor of four is a
10 - age 15 - date are you okay with
that
all right okay now remember all the
stuff I'm about to do I just want to
make this mentally easier for myself a
lot of it I don't need to do like I can
differentiate from this step I just it
just looks gross okay so everything I'm
gonna do is just to make things simpler
for me I don't like negatives especially
when they apply to a pruning rule
because then you have to bring into play
when you differentiate so I'm going to
get rid of them if I put a negative on
this in turn any of them miss they'll
cancel right so therefore I'm just gonna
change those borders now that's gonna be
H minus 10 that's gonna be H minus 15
did you see what I did
in some ways you didn't really need to
do that but it just makes it easier for
you okay now this this is a product I
can use product rule but why is product
rule when I can just expand this and not
have to deal with a product I just used
my power rule that's super easy to do so
therefore this is going to become a
quadratic and I know what the pair of
numbers is so therefore sorry in square
it's may gonna add to 25 and they're
gonna multiply to 150 are you okay with
that
come on we've gotten to the point where
we don't need to pair up these things
anymore and do first outside inside luck
don't do that right you guys know how
quadratics work so do this in Reverse
okay all right now one more step one
more step even though this looks pretty
good right I still have a product at the
moment I would still have to do vu -
plus UV - right so therefore even though
it seemed to be counterintuitive that H
I'm gonna put it back in like this okay
I think I'm ready now this is about as
good as it can get for differentiation
because I have a power of constant out
the front coefficient which is not going
to affect things or you can just have
them write it down and then these guys
this is this is as easy as it gets
isn't it okay so now we can get the
derivative DV on D H okay I said go for
out the front and then I'm just going to
go through what's that time yeah why
don't you use B - Paige oh I can I just
done as I've said I tend to use dashes
as little as possible that's just a
person with me
in fact if you like you go ahead and do
it I've been coming to it as you guys
like you will mean to interpret the
notation but I just live for myself
I've miss miss written this enough times
to try and avoid it if I can okay sir
now this differentiate shall we um tell
me what's right very good takeaway good
plus done okay so I differentiate it
great I had that skill at my belt but
what was the point of doing that I want
to find turning points right I want to
find turning points I'm not interested
in stationary points mark that we know
how much they overlap but stationary
points have no used to me if they are
horizontal points inflection all I
wanted to turn your points so therefore
I say turning points may exist may may
right when that's riveted is zero okay I
in other words this thing is equal to
zero somebody
okay now I look at that and it takes me
about six to seven seconds to say forget
that I am NOT even gonna bother trying
any factorization I have the quadratic
formula it is exactly four questions
like this where it's just like just
gross just cut your losses and start the
start performing often substitutive so
I'm just gonna say straight for this
line H equals I can ignore that for why
can I go the for one buy everything
right so just thinking about it if I
gave you this function you know where
its roots are right I should say I know
where its solutions are
okay now where are the solutions to this
well they are exactly the same point all
I've done is to stretch that parabola
vertically but the ridge to stay put
okay so the answers to this are the same
as the answers to this okay so I'm just
gonna take these guys in here as my a B
and C so let's do that minus b plus or
minus square root of okay you tell me
what's gonna go on anything square root
of 2500 take away 454 times a hundred
and fifty that's a see right there you
came with that all over 450 okay all
over what six to eight okay now I'm just
gonna pause you for a second okay I'm
getting two stationary points why am I
getting two stationary points because
well okay this is a quadratic
I expect a quadratic to have on two
solutions but why should volume have two
stationary points it's um what kind of
function is this it's a cue dated right
usually a cube equal guard like up and
then down it'll turn it two points right
so here are my two tiny points okay so
that's not a surprise
it is a little bit surprised because I'm
expecting that one of them and only one
as the actual
maximum volume so let's work out and see
what happens okay can we simplify this
to what we can get what comes underneath
the square root
2500 takeaway at the 18 that should be
1800 right yes hey I got 2 all over 6
okay so far so good now I can simplify
this a little bit more huge in that but
I can say that's 50 takeaway think of
your service right and I would take out
I can take out 100 which is 10 and then
that's on 6 so I can tidy that up just a
tiny little bit I'm getting that I don't
think I can go much further than that
are you ok with that ok now I have a
couple of choices of where I can go here
right I have two stationary points
because I know what cubics roughly look
like I'm expecting one of them to be a
relative minimum is fine and want to be
relative maximum that guy right so I
could go ahead and I could determine the
nature of my two stationary points
they'll be perfectly valid but it would
take me some time right like I have to
test your points
is there anything suspicious about these
points you know let me let me just make
a statement right away which actually is
not relevant to this question but the
most common thing that happens when you
get two values here right every
everything here is in positive numbers
do you agree like they're all legs
they're all measurements okay very
frequently when you solve this you will
find that one of the answers is negative
all right like if this number is bigger
than this number then the whole thing is
negative and then you have a negative
height right so you can exclude that out
of the domain because it doesn't work
okay
as it happens though you've got your
calculator there but right what's 5 root
7
three points yeah you've given me the
whole answer yeah I just want five root
seven five or seven is on just a bit
over 13 okay just a bit over 13 so what
you've got here is two answers when you
take away you'll be positive and when
you add you'll still be positive right
so both of those seem like they're kind
of okayed except the fact that they're
not